moi je vois ma condamné c'est moi
j'étais condamné mais par médiatiquement
parlant j'ai pas été condamné par la
justice il y a rien et il y aura jamais
rien donc en fait aujourd'hui la vérité
je dois m'y faire c'est que je serai
sali avis peut-être qu'il y a des gens
qui auront toujours un petit doute oui
mais il y avait pas de preuve et là oui
mais il y avait pas de fille si vous
gagnez votre procès pour diffamation là
vous aurez peut-être blanchi à ce
moment-là et pourquoi bah parce que si
jamais on voit que tout ça et tout ça se
passe pas comme ça en France qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont dire les gens oui mais il y
avait pas de preuve donc elle a pas plus
où est-ce qu'il a dit
c'est pas alors Ilan ton surnom c'est
Ilan le Charroux je pense c'est à cause
du tort ça le Charo ça veut dire voilà
ouais mais c'est ce qui m'a créé mais
c'est ce qui m'a créé c'est à dire que
je vais pas rogner qui je suis encore
une fois
alors attention j'ai pris une claque
dans la gueule pendant un an c'est pas
j'ai changé c'est j'ai évolué c'est à
dire qu'à un moment donné
bon ben voilà tu te fais rattraper par
la réalité qui fait que j'ai joué de ce
personnage qui était moi 80% oui j'étais
un séducteur et oui j'ai profité et bien
et je vais pas mentir mais ça fait pas
de moi un violeur ou un pointeur ou
pédophile ils ont rajouté mais c'est des
dingueries aujourd'hui je pense que pour
un homme il y a pas pire comme insulte
sur terre
je l'ai quand c'est quand c'est arrivé
j'étais quand je vous dis au fond du
trou Marco il était Marco m'avait vu à
l'époque tu te rappelles j'étais au fond
du trou il faut la raconter
de rigoler je vais un rendez-vous chez
Magali ça fait plaisir les potes comme
toi
les mecs comme ça dans comment ils sont
je rigole quand car rien fait
normalement tu dois pas être malheureux
désolé moi j'ai rien fait même la
escroquerie je l'ai pas fait pour moi
donc je suis bien je suis clair je suis
clair dans mes bottes j'ai pas de
problème c'est quand tu as fait tu as
peur donc quand tu as pas fait tu as pas
peur mais quand j'étais le voir je le
connaissais pas Magalie me l'a présenté
j'ai vu
les garçons le premier baiser et la
vérité je l'ai vu en dessous son lit non
en dessous son lit pas dire un mot et
puis j'ai remarqué quelque chose que sa
meuf qui avait ta meuf à l'époque elle a
pris le dessus sur lui
j'ai rien fait
vraiment tu es quand même quelqu'un qui
me permet vraiment c'est grâce à toi on
voit le bout du tunnel attends quand tu
vois un truc de rire tu vois la
différence après le mec il est arrivé en
forme d'un seul coup il a fait une
connerie la meuf c'est elle reprend lui
il est là il est timide et tu vois mais
j'arrive pas à comprendre là tu reviens
dans les réseaux et en fait j'ai oublié
je vais te poser une question
il travaille là-bas mais là normalement
tu reviens dans les réseaux mais en fait
tous les 5 minutes parce que j'ai jamais
quitté les réseaux parce que j'essaie de
garder la face mais le problème
aujourd'hui il est il est où
je suis sur les réseaux j'ai une
audience incroyable et ma communauté je
les remercie tous les jours ils m'ont
soutenu la meuf qui parle les gens il y
a pas la victime
non en fait c'est quelqu'un a dit j'ai
vu Ilan dans une vidéo
c'est même pas quelqu'un qui a dit il
m'a fait
j'ai vu quelqu'un dans une vidéo est le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas
ça c'est que vous savez comment ça
marche les réseaux quand vous elle
s'est en décoller on dirait chevalier
Laspalès depuis
je vais t'expliquer un truc aujourd'hui
les réseaux comment ça déjà moi la télé
je vous dis la vérité
j'ai essayé de me battre parce que moi
je suis quelqu'un de super optimiste
donc j'ai toujours cru que Ben à un
moment donné ça se passerait que même si
je gagne mon procès admettons ça se
passe bien et je puisse reprendre ma vie
en fait juste reprendre ma vie mais on
m'a remis à la réalité en me disant Ilan
je te dis la vérité avec ce qui s'est
passé oublie ta carrière la télé s'est
terminée